les bons baisers de russie attendront
encore un peu ce lundi le président du
conseil européen charles michel s'est
entretenu par téléphone avec vladimir
poutine
une discussion au cours de laquelle
selon un communiqué du conseil ont été
officialisés les tensions entre moscou
et bruxelles
le président michel a estimé qu'elle
relations ue-russie était un point bas
et a confirmé la proche de lui eu des
cinq principes directeurs basée sur les
valeurs fondamentales de l'union
européenne source de ces dissensions les
accords de minsk
les cyber attaques contre les états
membres imputé par lieu à la russie ou
encore le sujet des droits de l'homme et
les vaccins un sujet épineux puisque la
veille au soir thierry breton
commissaire européen en charge des
vaccins a balayé d'un revers de main
tout recours au vaccin rue spoutnik vais
pourtant examiné par les autorités
sanitaires européennes
une déclaration qui n'a guère été du
goût des fabricants du vaccin qu'ils
estiment efficace à plus de 91% et qui
ont vivement réagi sur twitter ce lundi
cheikh commissaire breton arrêtez de
faire preuve de partialité
les européens veulent un choix de
vaccins sûrs et efficaces que vous
n'avez pas encore fourni spoutnik v et
déjà enregistrés dans 54 pays
s'il s'agit d'une position officielle de
l'ue eux veuillez nous informer qu'il
n'y a aucune raison de demander
l'approbation de l'om a en raison de vos
préjugés politiques
nous continuerons de sauver des vies
dans d'autres pays
moscou avait déjà accusé les instances
européennes de volontairement ralentir
le processus d'homologation du vaccin
russe vladimir poutine lui n'a
d'ailleurs que modérément apprécié les
propos de thierry breton une déclaration
étrange
nous n'imposons rien à personne en
europe nombreux sont ceux qui ne savent
pas que la réussie a déposé il ya
longtemps une demande d'enregistrement
de son vaccin auprès de l'agencé
européenne des médicaments
cela a été fait comme tatiana golikova
ghoul a rapporté ce matin le 21 janvier
et ce n'est que le 4 mars que nous avons
été informés du fait que notre demande
commencer à être examinées je tiens à
dire à cet égard comme je viens de
l'indiquer que nous n'imposons rien à
personne
mais quand nous entendons des
représentants officiels faire de telles
déclarations une question s'impose
quel intérêt défendent et représentent
de telles personnes les intérêts de
sociétés pharmaceutiques ou ceux des
citoyens des pays européens grâce qu'ils
font du lobbying
le président russe qui a déclaré qu'il
se ferait vacciner contre le coc vide
quant à ce pique nique v il parvient
tout de même à trouver acquéreur avec ou
sans commande européenne alors qu'un
accord de production de 200 millions
d'unités a été conclu ces jours ci avec
l'inde
ce lundi un demi million de doses
supplémentaires sont arrivés en
argentine premier pays d'amérique latine
à l'avoir approuvé le 23 décembre
dernier